mit installiertes zurück also willkommen
bei mcdonald's ihre bestellung
und nach schicken bitte
[Musik]
hallo
heute machen wir was megatrucks und zwar
probieren wir die bestellung von leuten
über eine bluetooth box bei mcdonald's
zu ändern das bedeutet wir entscheiden
einfach was die leute heute essen und
probieren die leute ein bisschen die
nähere zukunft das funktioniert ob die
mac ist mitarbeiter das checken ob wir
eine anzeige bekommen bis dunkel wie
viel zu spät angefangen zu drehen seht
ihr jetzt netto krönchen gleich wenn wir
das nach so unangenehm sein wir haben
den parkplatz der am nächsten an reifen
ist ja vorne an dem laternenfest hält
glaube ich unser größter gegner
was ist denn gerade in dem moment wo wir
die box platzieren jemand auf diesen
überwachungs bildschirm schaut viel
glück im leben ist hinter uns steht so
benz ich glaube ist ein fahrservice oder
so recht das ist mit ansage werden sich
auf geräte niemals würde ich das machen
läuft dir zu erläutern weshalb brauchen
die kamera so bitter wenn jetzt jemand
haus kommen die wave direkt belastet
wird
red installiertes zeigt jetzt das
institut glaube ich so als würde sich
das angucken und da kommt er wieder
zurück und da ist auch schon der erste
kunde terry newton 2
das klappt sollen wir die irgendwie so
drei kameras vier mikrofone selbst oder
erste blick wenn die größe und das mit
die verachten ins team rückte gleich
fertig wenn jemand irgendwas bestellen
da hängt man check das nicht nur an von
reinfällen hälfte muss einen juden juden
sie hat uns aber beobachtet jedoch nicht
hallo willkommen bei mcdonald's ihre
bestellung mit
und mein
seinen titel
nein
fenster zwei bitte
[Musik]
das nicht schon zu viel war das könnte
schon zu viel
und dann kommt ja nicht so dass einen
eine bestellen lassen wir mal so redet
okay es kleine also wenn jemand von
mcdonald's rauskommt sehen die uns
instant wir setzen direkt am drive in
wir haben licht an und hier liegen so
drei kameras nicht probieren einfach zu
reden
hallo hallo ich will jetzt bestellen
[Musik]
und noch ein chicken bald anbieten
ohne vermitteln
wir sind so aufgeführt
oder geht nicht um mich aus
mit
dann haben wir mal einen spärlich
[Musik]
b
[Applaus]
[Musik]
er geht nur in die pause er hat davon
nichts mitbekommen
es ist von mir ich soll ja sorry ist von
mir sagt er ja kein problem tritt sie
einfach um und geht weiter mein gott da
er bei andererseits wir hatten jetzt die
möglichkeit so richtig schön keen raus
zu sein
ja aber ich will kann es kritiker die
vierte klasse können wenn ich krank
[Musik]
ergänzt
einzeln
[Musik]
einwohner
hat aber die machen wir nicht
vorweg
[Musik]
einige
weil er so hoch saß in der g klasse
dabei übels korrekt ich habe die sachen
weggenommen
doch bevor die mitarbeiter da waren wir
haben ja ein bisschen groß reingekriegt
ja der hat sie mir ein bisschen versaut
[Musik]
das bei max hat jetzt schon ziemlich gut
funktioniert aber wir brauchen noch ein
bisschen was wir uns überlegt am eingang
eines baumarktes die leute einfach mal
ein bisschen zu begrüßen und ihnen paar
komplimente mit auf den weg zu nehmen
wenn ich das video bis hierhin gefallen
hat lassen leichter abonniert nicht und
dann kommt mehr von dem kram viel spaß
hallo
eine wahrlich coole mütze
[Gelächter]
vielen dank für ihren einkauf
hallo ich habe danke gesagt hallo und
herzlich willkommen in ihrem toom
baumarkt hallo mein bester
schöne haben sie
sagen sie jetzt laut hatte diesen
einkauf bei toom baumarkt gefallen hat
hallo hallo ich bin unsichtbar
[Gelächter]
diese gelben lilien sind wirklich
wunderschön
und schadet ihrer gesundheit kurz doch
die blumen landschaften und dann geht's
raus und rein mit ihnen
nicht so lange zuhören bei dem
kleinformat zu greifen
nein dann zeigen beim nächsten mal auf
die plätze leider haben die meisten
leute erst auf unserer komplimente
reagiert als sie schon aus dem bild
heraus gelaufen sind ich habe trotzdem
spaß und ich wollte euch die aufnahme
nicht verteilen sofern ihr das was mit
diesem video ich hoffe es hat euch
gefallen das war ein vorzüglicher spaß
bis das gefallen hat und ihr mehr bock
auf sowas hab dann last leichter
abonniert mich und wir sehen uns zu tage
vielleicht das setup jetzt einmal aber
mit der kamera und dem bluetooth speaker
und sowohl könnte ich das noch mal
schreibt mir das in die kommentare
ich wäre sehr dankbar ich habe lust mehr
solche videos zu machen wir hatten sehr
viel spaß dabei
was gut bis die tagesschau
[Musik]